-Thank you for taking time
out of this busy week.
-Man, yes of course.
I wanted to see you.
I wanted to see you...
-Yeah.
-...ever since you said some
nice stuff about my special.
-Your special -- and I want to
talk about your special --
is "100% fresh."
-Yes, yes.
-Is as good a comedy special
as I've seen in years.
It made me so happy.
-Thank you so much.
And thanks for saying
the nice stuff.
All my friends
sent me your tweet
and all the nice stuff you said,
so thank you.
-And that's good.
I mean, I gotta be honest,
I think a tweet from me
is gonna be real good for you.
-I think it's healthy.
It's healthy.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, it's gonna be really...
[ Laughs ]
-Why -- It's been 20-plus years,
maybe almost 25 years,
since you left "SNL."
-Right.
-I mean, I have to imagine
you've been asked to host
over the years.
What made now the right time?
-It was a mistake.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-They caught me
in a weak moment.
No, those guys are great.
I... [ Stammers ]
The special came out,
and then some guys from
"Saturday Night Live" called me
and said, "Come on, come host"
and blah blah blah.
And they were talking about,
you know,
watching the special together.
I said, "Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're right, man.
Let me come do it."
And I love Lorne
and I wanted to see Lorne
and do it with him
and be on the show
and bring back some nice --
But I've gotta tell you,
it's knocked me out.
I'm so knocked out right now.
-Yeah.
Also, I think the difference --
'cause, you know, I went back
this year as well.
They asked me, like,
a week beforehand.
-Oh yeah?
-So I didn't have --
'Cause you've had some time
to think about it.
-Yes, yes, yes.
-Have you had stress coming in?
'Cause it's been, like,
months that you've known.
-Yes. Yes. I've been very --
I've been watching the show
and I've been laughing.
And I was, "Oh, man, that guy
is good" or "She's good."
And I'm nervous about me.
And now...
[ Laughter ]
But I just --
it's really been, like --
This week...
-It's so hard.
-It really is a knockout.
I should have --
First of all, I should have
come back to the show
before there was HD.
[ Laughter ]
Because now I'm like,
"Good Lord, I waited
a long, long time.
"I don't really look
like Adam Sandler anymore,
but that's all right."
But -- but I'm just -- yeah, no.
I am -- I'm gonna --
-Have you -- I know backstage,
I saw some of the guys
you used to write with --
-Yeah.
-...back in the day.
You came back.
-Yes.
-Has that been nice
having them around?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Herlihy and Smigel
and Steve Koren
and all my guys that were
on the show with me back then
and wrote a lot of stuff I did.
The writing staff was
very nice to 'em.
It was good. They feel like me.
when I went there, and they're
so good and so young.
And so you do go, "Oh, my God.
I don't belong here."
[ Laughter ]
-I would assume, like me,
you would stay very late
on Tuesday nights, writing.
-Yes.
-Did you try that at all
this time?
Or were out of there pretty --
-I did.
-Oh, you did?
-I did one night.
The Tuesday night one.
-Yeah.
-When you do
"Saturday Night Live,"
you write the skits, like,
Monday, Tuesday kind of thing.
And a lot of guys stay late
Tuesday, or the women.
And I stayed till, like, 4:00.
-Oh, that's pretty impressive.
-It wasn't bad.
-Yeah.
-I came back. I was delirious.
I was nasty.
[ Laughter ]
Nasty to the hotel guy
when my key wasn't ready.
I was like, "Come on, man!"
I was a little psychotic
but I-I'm good.
I have not bounced back
from that yet.
Tonight, I gotta sleep, though.
-That's good.
And I would imagine
that you're --
I feel like everybody at
this point has, like,
a very bad
Adam Sandler impression.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
-And I always found that was
a fun week to write on the show.
Christopher Walken,
everybody has a bad one.
-Right, right.
-And I remember
when he would host,
if you would walk down the hall,
you'd hear every writer, like,
typing and doing it in
Walken's voice.
You'd be like, "Oh, my God.
Everybody is talking like
Christopher Walken this week."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yes, that happened at the show.
I did hear through the door
on occasion...
"Oh, ya wa ya, boy."
I was like, "Oh, come on."
[ Laughter ]
-"You know, switch it up.
We gotta show my range."
-Yeah, I do other stuff.
No, I actually don't.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you go...
Your office, I know this
from legend, is really
a Murderer's Row sort of
Mount Rushmore of that era.
-Yeah.
-You, Farley, Spade, and Rock
all shared an office.
-Right, yes.
We were in the back.
I went and visited --
it's not --
We're not there anymore.
It's -- "Weekend Update" is
in our office.
-Yeah.
-So yeah, I was really --
it was nice to see.
But I did look
at Farley's old desk
and I thought of the crazy...
[ Laughs ]
Just him being funny there
and just the fun times we had.
And I know the "Weekend Update"
guys who were sitting
are a lot smarter than we are...
[ Laughter ]
...and a lot of different
conversations going on.
-Was it --
I mean, the level of filth
in some of the offices
is stunning.
-Yes.
-Certainly in my era, too.
-Was yours --
And by "filth," I mean a lack
of cleanliness.
-Yes, yes, yes.
-Were you guys an uncleanly --
-Nobody picked up much.
Farley, you know,
he didn't pick up much.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-And Spade, you know, he wasn't
as filthy as Farley or me.
Rock kind of
took care of himself
a little bit better than us.
But we did hit McDonald's a lot.
Did you guys used to do that?
-Yeah.
-You'd walked out --
-Did you go out on your own?
'Cause I do feel bad
'cause my memory is
we would maybe send interns
out to McDonald's.
-You did?
-Yeah.
-No, we went there.
We got excited to be in Mc--
I think we were excited
to get recognized back then.
-Okay.
-It was like, "Oh, man,
I think the lady gave me
extra cheese or something."
[ Laughter ]
I don't know.
-So you would go out
fishing for --
you were, like,
one of those people
who put your hood up
and sunglasses. Yeah.
-No, that just happened
this year.
But, I mean...
[ Laughter ]
...I was definitely
walking down the street,
like, after a Saturday show.
If I did well on the show
and I was, you know,
23 years old, my God,
I was walking down the street
and staring people in the eye.
Like, "That's right.
It's me, man."
[ Laughter ]
-I remember every now and then,
they would give you, like --
the Christmas gift
would be, like,
a duffel bag that they'd give
to the cast.
It would be a duffel bag
with "SNL" on the side.
And you'd have to say,
"Well, I can't use this."
-Right, right, right.
-'Cause I feel like
if I wear it,
it's like me desperately trying
to get people to, like,
"Huh? Huh?"
[ Laughter ]
Seemed like you would have
jumped at that duffel bag.
-I'd be all over
the bag back then.